[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i didn't know one asian person until i
was 26 years old
that's incredible i didn't know one
asian person
but you've seen you saw them around like
at a ball but yeah but i didn't like you
know i didn't like super interactive
like i was like
hey man you guys are asian i'm bert you
guys want to meet up and
you know because i want to defend it
though too is that um
you know what you were running into were
fresh off the boat people
you know when people come here from a
different country they they
they stick asians that we stick to
ourselves right we have these little
meetings and you know like that um the
guy cho
the guy that showed up virginia attack
yeah they couldn't get a hold
of none of the news media could get a
hold of his parents to interview them
because the asian community harbored
them right and they yeah and they took
them off the market
and they left and then they sent them
into korea and no one could interview
them or anything that's how
asians are we're very secretive i'm so
badass though yeah
you like that like i wish i wish like i
saw black panther and i was like i part
of it was like
i was like i wish they had one of these
for white guys like you know
i know i know i know i realize that
later but like batman
my point is black panthers
if i owed you let's say 15 years ago
okay you gave me you loaned me three
thousand dollars right okay and then you
know i'm doing okay now in life right
but i never brought it up
would you ever say anything no i talked
behind your back
i talked behind your back and tucked
behind your back we talked [ __ ]
that's exactly what i do i had a friend
ask me for
four thousand dollars very recently
and he was like don't tell your wife and
i was like i'm [ __ ]
i've already told her like i don't know
what you're talking about
and so then my wife's like what are you
gonna do and i said i'm gonna give him
the money
and then i'm just gonna hate him
why would you do that i go on man give
him the money hate him and then tell
everyone he asked for four thousand
dollars
four thousand dollars and i was like
and these are like these are i think
probably what what is when you just come
free is that
that's not first generation that's first
generation is
me no yeah one before you that's the all
these moms are that immigrants
they're immigrants yeah i'm not gonna
say that word but yeah okay you can't
say immigrants
i don't think i'm around
[Laughter]
in your hands
no but so they i told one of the moms i
said i really like this what is this
he said it's kimchi and i was like
really and she goes yeah you know how
it's made she tells me about how it's
made and i know i find that fascinating
that you bury it
and then you dig it up but they didn't
do that for them but so i said i would
i love this i want more she goes i'll
bring you some tomorrow brings me a
five gallon glass jar of kimchi i ate
this kimchi for a [ __ ] year
my neighbor my neighbor was a was a chef
named roy choi roy he was my next-door
neighbor and our kids are the same age
yeah yeah
do i know him personally i think so
are you friends i love them i love you
roy
a couple of times when i've been on the
road um the middle act who i fly out or
whoever
will always go will sometimes go i'm
just gonna take off
oh
no like while you're on stage i'm just
gonna go take off no you're not no
you're not yeah yeah yeah no you're not
and i always [ __ ] agree
and the bird i always go yeah go have
fun
you know and then they take off but then
when i'm on stage i'm thinking about
them the whole time
yeah i'm getting louds and i'm like
where the [ __ ] is he where's he going uh
that's so important wow yeah i worked i
was getting ready to do a special and i
worked with
a person i won't say anything i won't
say anything
this is by the way this is i mean this
is
[Music]
uh and i worked with a person and i s
and i got
off stage thursday all shows sold out
right
great room great room portland helium
i like that room yeah get off show stage
thursday and i go to the green room i'm
like where's dr dot and they're like oh
they went
home i went oh so i texted him i said
are you feeling sick
and they said no just getting to bed
early
i went cool friday two shows
after the first show yeah they're not
home they went for a walk
like they got off stage and went for a
walk show back up for the second show
and i was like hey you're gonna hang out
tonight and they're like nah probably
not and i went okay
saturday comes around and i'm [ __ ]
fuming
i am you yeah and i say hey just so you
know you're not that funny
yes it came out that way it came out it
spilled out and they went what i said i
didn't bring you here
because i think you're brilliant
i didn't you're not here because you're
funny at all you're here because i need
someone to be around
i can't be by myself wow and i can't be
around
and now i'm now i'm stuck i i would
rather do a one-man show if you're not
gonna be here
yeah and and that person was like oh
okay
well i can hang out tonight and i was
like yeah oh no no
no you can't you're going to hang out
tonight you're going to sit at that bar
and you're going to drink i don't care
if you're in [ __ ] rehab
you're going to drink it and then you're
going to tell me how great my show was
you're going gonna watch my whole show
wow by the way barely
listen to what i'm saying because i kind
of i don't know what i'm talking about
yeah
but um but i think korean math is a lot
like playing the violin
okay yep he's the wrong person i think
that
disagree with the same thing the same
way to play the violin is how you learn
math and korean and
asian math is easier than white math
don't take my word on this i kind of
listened to
this
let me say what i'm going to say okay
all right and then you can say i'm going
to call my wife
don't call your wife no because she
would know what i'm trying to say yeah
but what i'm just saying is that i
thought numbers were a universal thing
no no no it's not but it's how you learn
the math you learn the math is very
different
because korean math was was easier to
understand than
than uh colonial math so
so they would teach them math in korean
and it would and that's why
math scores were through the roof and
someone's got to have my back on this
because
or at least explain what the [ __ ] is
that kind of like how rocky trained and
ivan drago trained
right right yeah rocky trained in the
forest with logs on his back
yes check chasing chickens yeah and ivan
drago had
the futuristic yeah yeah yeah yeah and
the wires and tubes and yeah yeah and it
is all based on the violin
i know that makes sense when you're
playing music you see a note you don't
calculate what the note is you go oh
that's a b i hit a b
so they the way i i took kumon's is
three and two you don't go what's three
plus two you go
the combination three what's cool is a
mathematic like tutorial center you
[ __ ] i was sitting here hanging
out to drive for forever
i didn't do this [ __ ] i wanted to see
your explanation i wanted to see mother
[ __ ] this mother's [ __ ] right here
you know what he just did
and i want to apologize you know what he
did what you just like the white guy you
try to hang on well you just did to my
friend right
with sabotage and you made him look like
a fool and he's our guest and i want you
to apologize right now
mr christchure i apologize thank you
[ __ ] you i took
my tour bus driver and my tour manager
this is not this tour but the previous
one we were in
columbus ohio for the night and i said
hey let's go out to eat
and they were like okay so i took them
to uh
smith and wilinski's really nice
restaurant and the tour bus driver is
like
just looking at the menu and he's wow
these are these prices are out of my my
price i go i'm paying and he goes
looks at me he goes you're playing well
then i'm getting the most expensive
and i was like this tour bus driver was
a [ __ ]
nightmare he really was you know he said
to me one time he goes we're in boston
he goes uh
hey he one time i'm ready eating
breakfast he goes i'm gonna ask you a
question feel free to say no and i went
uh the answer is no
[Laughter]
i'll tell you what don't answer the
question don't ask questions
if you're thinking i'm gonna say no i'm
going to probably say no and he goes
well i want to run it by you and i said
don't
don't run it by me just know that the
answer is no and he goes i was wondering
if we could bring my wife on tour and i
was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me you want your
wife to be on the tour bus living with
us
you hey i want my wife too [ __ ]
[ __ ] one time he says he goes he goes i
was wondering
when you're in boston you got two shows
there two nights or four shows there you
got two nights yeah
i was wondering i could just take off
and go home early you get a hotel
and i was like yeah yeah no i've already
paid for my hotel it's the tour bus
yeah i'm not gonna pay for that and then
oh it was the most i
hate people like that are you dipping no
but it dipped for a long time you did
yeah is that bad for you nah dude i
don't know if you can't
really really she thinks it's bad for
you yeah i don't think you can really
get cancer cancer's not real
he's right but you know i don't hear i
mean this i hear a lot of
people that smoke get lung cancer oral
cancer is probably
but i don't see people like you want to
look like um roger ebert with half of
his face
but he didn't dip he just um what i'm
saying
or something that's what oral cancer and
cancer like that area causes
oh it does dude that was the picture
they passed around to us in baseball
when we were kids it was the guy who
just dipped for four years and lost his
bottom jaw yeah yeah oh they shoot the
picture yeah but it's not real
that's not real you can't get you can't
get lip cancer that quick
i mean roger ebert was like 70 or
something
it is real oral cancer is very real but
i don't think it shows up
that quick unless like you're prone to
cancer i mean children also get cancer
also
that's why anything is everything's
cancerous
everything has you know but is there a
guy is there a guy
on earth that dipped since he was 18 and
he's now 90 and he doesn't have cancer
uh my wife's
my wife's dad has been chewing tobacco
since he was
13. my wife's grandfather chewed tobacco
until
since when he was a child like seven
probably and they haven't completely
faced
90. yeah never it's it's a lot
also it's about oral hygiene i i think i
don't know i don't know
yeah yeah but i'm listening yeah but i
am listening i like it
will you be my doctor please yeah on my
own i'm not quitting anything
yeah go ahead yeah i think it's about
like flossing and yeah yeah
and brushing right so if i dip and i
floss i use listerine
and i brush two or three times a day i
might not get cancer okay might not you
won't
100 yeah i don't know why we're
ballparking this why not take big swings
yeah yeah
three two one we go together
remember the grease yep remember the
grease at the end when they were
freaking everyone out
at the end when they're celebrating at
the [ __ ] amusement park or whatever
or when they're all friends already
yeah they're friends and then they start
singing oh
something just came out of my mouth it
was a tooth what yeah something flew
because i just flew it
like a tooth fell out it's all right
it's not a tooth that's not a tube nope
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i know but i have to do a whole intro
bro okay okay what the [ __ ] dude
so at the end of greece um give me a
head in paper
get him a pen and paper from from the
outskirt right
you look like um something i might not
like
oh everyone says that yeah yeah yeah
like if i ever
if i was like if i was in let's say i
was in indiana
and i'm lost right yeah and i'm in a
corn field
and i see you with that hat at the whole
thing oh yeah i'll go i need directions
but that's not the guy
everyone says that but you are the guy
do i'm the sweetest guy i understand
that but i'm just saying
in the beginning you didn't seem like
the guy i look like a meat head and i
come off like a like a hard penis like
i'm like
yeah like everyone's like oh and i'm
loud and obnoxious and like yeah say
[ __ ] up things like
and i don't i don't want you to take
this the wrong way okay right
but i really enjoy your lips
by the way that's one of the things
something about his lips
is really puffy in the right ways it
looks like a really great look it looks
like a [ __ ]
i'll take it yeah good yeah yeah you
have [ __ ] lips i had a girl
my favorite first girls i ever made out
with said i really like
your lips i like your lips are soft i
swear to god for like five years after
that i kiss like this
like no muscle in my lip yeah
[Music]
just the wrong way